hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the impossible quiz
mistype laid a long time ago this is
made by the same perp there it is oh the
memories okay alright let's do this
wow that is loud okay on the first day
of impossible Christmas my true love
gave to me wow you're so loud okay alan
partridge in a pear tree hepatitis B a
Satsuma a lecture on thermodynamics I
don't know what a susume is alan
partridge in a pear tree why is that
wrong a Satsuma hepatitis-b
oh okay sure who'd rape spaghetti over
Scrooge's chest my god shut up wait what
just wait yeah and that question kind of
glanced over me who draped spaghetti
over Scrooge's chest the ghost of
Christmas pasta the ghost of Christmas
present the ghost of Christmas yet to
come
the devil himself I'm gonna go that one
give I give up
alright I guess I don't give up fine
hepatitis No hepatitis B yeah the ghost
of Christmas pasta yes what is this
waving salt season's greetings pepper
people under bomba nation I'm gonna go
Seasons Greece hey find the dodgy bulb
was it this one Oh
what makes Rudolph's nose glow red elf
dandruff Santa's bumper Santa's years of
alcohol abuse I'm gonna go that one hey
well I don't know what's happening here
Lulla Lulla
laughs lela lela lela know what's going
on who wrote the song silent night Franz
Xaver Gruber Carol
[Music]
Carol what turbo flapper why the bumhole
rhubarb goes here ah the dead Beatty
ball ah do oh wait what Oh what is this
this Nativity the true meaning of
Christmas sweet baby cheats sweet baby
Jesus all right find the dodgy ball
forgot it okay
wrote the songs twelve days of Christmas
Carol ha Carol okay not the turbo
flapper the tail-end water must be
chilly no tail end no seasonal headwear
well [ __ ] okay have a nice big rose
occurs behind Oh Oh what is this punchy
paper a calendar boiled cabbage Boxing
Day who wrote the little donkey Carol de
perfil okay and not the bumhole whoa
okay all right well hot Jets of duck
sputum I don't know what you've won for
me with the doc harder to do you do wait
wait
tiny throbbing swollen member no I know
what to do I know what to do I know - I
just saw it what is this beefy bill a
bauble Christmas dinner pig dog beefy
bill damn it a bauble okay sure whatever
[Music]
okay all right whatever
all right move ah that was horrible why
the hell did you make this game in flash
it's all I know this quiz was starting
to do that for all the authentic
slightly ropey impossible quiz
experience because flash the bigger the
local online entertainment so I know
[ __ ] started in 2000 that well alright
never mind then for that authentic
slightly ropey impossible oh here we go
frank says press six six G I be l.e.d.s
giblets
oh that's weird
oh wait where do you find a curve
believer tree uh in your stockings no
Christmas tree
no on the roof Oh what is this tinsel
deathball
event shell meaty treats I don't know
what that is death ball damn tinsel tin
soul
ah hey n G L e/s angles hey-oh goof in a
bear trap no skip oh it was a gift
oh he was a gift it was a gift he left
my Christmas present in the gift whoa
so now there's a Christmas quiz how
about a Halloween special to light this
question is Halloween special I can't be
arsed too spoopy Oh pumpkin no okay
all right well Oh question was it how
would you rate this quiz so far solid
six at ten almost too Christmasy it's
all six out of ten okay never mind then
okay it's almost due Chris Massie oh
this guy's originals ooh
[Music]
brutally honest mediocre well never mind
then
it's a trick question okay all right
then oh yes hey are oh you ts sprouts oh
okay there's some oh oh oh oh wait
there's something on here what's going
on who's on there who's naked on their
hair come on now what are you doing
under all this holly jolly holly how's
uh how's the family what's uh what's
what's going on here you can't tell me
he's gonna be a [ __ ] huh oh hello the
mistletoe I found it I found it
whoa got a skip apparently but found
that hey where do pirates hide their
Xmas presents in a massive chest under a
palm tree pirates don't celebrate
Christmas in the bowels of the Kraken in
the bowels of a Kraken
damn it under Bob tree oh where do
pirates hide their expose right here
yeah okay all right it was in the
prepare for takeoff okay honk wait
where's the I'll go wait Oh shooty I did
yeah Santa oh that that don't look right
that's that ain't oh boy that that son
man right here wait hang on
wait no no oh Satan I should have made
of Satan I should have made it Satan
[ __ ] go put this on there Wham okay and
we're gonna replace this oh we're gonna
replace these are hard to hit Satan whoa
whoa okay
[Music]
Oh Noel Noel and Easter ha I got a
Christmas cracker right butthole
butthole moon hole whoa okay I don't
know what I'm supposed to be doing here
or there we go how much does a venison
cost it's deer ha ha
the answer will be revealed to the
Christmas cracker
[Music]
Oh be real no what did I do
I don't know ah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
Oh a gift I love it well oh well well I
don't like looking to this oh wait what
what whatever Oh stomach don't look sick
Oh put that out what is a Turlock
somewhere you can stuff a turkey a city
in California
a Turkish wizard reindeer testes the
Turkish wizard [ __ ]
reindeer tizzies damn it somewhere you
can stuff a turkey
ro twas the night before Christmas when
all through the house not a creature was
stirring not even a mouse
Oh
[Music]
another map oh whoa whoa what did I do
I didn't do anything oh okay wait Oh God
Donner Prancer crasher Oh comet Blitzen
dancer Cupid - er ah I get it
not even a mouse was stirring ah I just
didn't move my mouse ah I get it
okay let's it comet Dasher Donner Cupid
crasher no dancer Prancer and boss know
that's giving oh this is 20 minutes time
to open your presents have you got any
oh no i got nothing i got crippling
depression oh no oh I needed that one oh
listen vixen dawn or Cupid Dasher common
dancer yay yay yay yay yay time to open
your presents have you got any I did it
but oh this one
yay oh just what I wanted all but
there's four others one in the duct
level maybe oh wait are you not supposed
to use those skips wait a minute whoa oh
so it has been ten years can you still
remember No so remember what
wait wait the original impossible quiz
color sequence wait I don't remember
[Music]
damn oh god damn it oh jeez I don't
remember
blue red okay blue red green well what
else is it supposed to be god damn it
blue red orange blue red red no blue red
blue green
oh come on blue red blue yellow yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
where's my collection page huh well
there's apparently some skips in there
that I don't know where they are but
that was never 100% good either getting
that but now it's fun that was a blast
from the past oh my god
holy [ __ ] well that's a lot of
opportunity so if you guys want to play
it I will link it in the description
below thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below
and thanks again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye